there is more concern this morning about
conditions inside detention centers
let's go to Gail who is along the
us-mexico border outside one of those
facilities in McAllen Texas Gail good
morning a lot of heartbreak down on that
border I'll say Alex you couldn't have
said it better than that wrenching
disturbing there are many adjectives we
could use here the photos we showed you
yesterday of undocumented immigrants
inside a Rio Grande Valley detention
facility are drawing intense reactions
today our doctor our David Wagner rather
was part of a select group of
journalists allowed inside and he
described what he saw as people in cages
now the Border Patrol didn't like that
they told us it was uncomfortable with
that characterization but they did not
say it was inaccurate for the first time
though we may be hearing from children
separated from their parents
investigative website Pro Publica
obtained a nearly eight-minute audio
recording that it claims reveals
children crying out inside a detention
facility civil rights attorney Jennifer
Harbury received the audio from a client
who says it was recorded last week now
we have to tell you that CBS News has
not been able to independently confirm
the authenticity of this recording which
is mostly in Spanish but here is a
portion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jennifer Harbor II has lived and worked
in the Rio Grande Valley for four
decades and joins us this morning
Jennifer thank you very much for coming
you know I don't speak Spanish but I
certainly know mami and papi and you
hear that anguish in the children's
voice what can you tell us about the
client and the conditions on how he or
she got this tape well it's very
important always to protect any
whistleblower from retaliation but I
can't say that that particular person I
have known and I certainly know of an is
of impeccable integrity the
whistleblower did in fact make that tape
recording in person in person and
brought it to me because this is really
the first time we've heard the children
you know they've allowed reporters in
but we have not been allowed to record
anything so this is really the first
time we're hearing children's voices but
before we go further how can you really
tell us explain to us that this is an
authentic tape I was on a plane the
other day and I heard children screaming
mommy and daddy how can we tell that it
was recorded there at a facility well at
the beginning of the tape you can hear a
heavy door clanging shot and people
saying okay you know in Spanish of
course that you know sort of getting the
children together and stuff all that I
can really say is that Ginger Thompson
of ProPublica did an amazing job there
is a small child who had memorized an
ant's phone number in that tape yeah and
she says let me call my aunt she's well
she's saying you call my aunt and tell
them to come here right away I'm all
alone on frightened and and she's
begging and crying Ginger Thompson in
fact called that person and yes the
little girl exists yes the little girl
is in detention and yes she was
frightened and yes she was separated
from her mother you're not telling us
the specific facility but what can you
tell us about the children in the
facility um there is a place or in the
facility is where children have been
brought after they were separated from
their parents those are the small
children like age 12 down to four that
you hear on the tape
there are also some teenage
that fled the cartels for example ramp
for their lives and their unaccompanied
for that reason and they're also in in
the back of that room what are you
saying to the Trump administration that
says listen these parents are putting
their children in danger we're not
putting these children in danger their
parents are doing that well I'd like to
give an example maybe if one client at
one point from a few years ago he turned
15 and Honduras and that's prime time
when the cartels arrive at your door and
say you're working for us or you're dead
they asked him the first time and he
said no I don't want to work for you
which was maybe not very diplomatic they
came the second time and ran him over
with a car he woke up three days later
with a head injury his mother a very
poor Campesina woman had managed to
round up 30 or $40 stuffed it into his
hands and said run and the point you're
making is these people are desperate is
that what you're saying yes parents are
trying to save their kids lives by
getting them up here as a as an attorney
who works with children what is your
take on all of this I'm what you're
seeing in here and you've seen more than
most of us I'm astounded on that America
of all places my father having arrived
at Ellis Island also frightened out of
us wits at age 11 that of all places
America was duped too traumatizing and
abusing children of refugees how can we
come to this if we want to go after the
cartels a hundred percent wonderful why
are we punishing their victims a lot of
people are asking that question thank
you very much for joining us so early
this morning we do appreciate it